Please save us,
we are in an earthquake under the rubble right now. Please, if
you love God, save us.
Mustafa Kemal
District, 9th Street, Hatay, Iskenderun
[Music] we
have a building.
Speak loudly [Music] There is
no one since the morning, no one is there,
the situation is deserted
[Music]
Oh, my brother's children were left at the bottom,
three children on top, one brother was not found in the middle. May
God help us. Let them pray for us.
[Music] We
heard voices. We were already drinking with our children.
What will we do?
We risked our lives, which were already half destroyed, but there is nothing
to do. What a Dawn.  There
are no soldiers or anyone. This is a place where things have been thrown away.